[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut tout le monde ce coupci vous
l'avez compris c'est une compile
spéciale des jeux Loney ton c'est bon
sans can ch je sais pas qui a fait le
plus de jeux à l'époque est-ce que c'est
Disney avec ses adaptations de film et
ses jeux Mick et Donald ou est-ce que
c'est Warner regarde ça il y en a
vraiment pour tout le monde il y a bug
Bunny Daffy Duck Titi et grominé Taz
Speedy gonzalz bip bip même Pory son
propre jeu le seul qui a pas eu son jeu
c'est pépé depuis toi pourtant moi
j'imagine sans problème ce qu'un jeu
pépé depu toi pourrait donner allez
viens mête je vais
t'attraper pourquoi il y a pas d'image
là parce que c'est une émission Tout
publique espèce de grand dégueulasse et
dans tout ce t de plastique il y a
vraiment eu des super jeux moi par
exemple j'avais adoré le jeu Titi et
grominé même si bon il était pas génial
et que le Titi en misteride me faisait
grave flipper il y avait les dizaines de
jeux Bugs Bunny et puis av aussi les
super jeux tiny tonses moi je me régalis
à y jouer avec des pote mais évidemment
c'est pas ça que vous voulez voir vous
hein alors des jeux de merde Looney
tonses il y en a eu il y en a eu plein
ne vous inquiétez pas il y a eu des jeux
avec un gameplay de merde il y a eu des
jeux juste impossibles et il y a eu des
jeux juste impossibles avec un gameplay
de merde et je vais commencer par Road
Runner des valer rally qu'on connait
nous en France sous le nom de Road
Runner Looney tonses sur Super
NES alors moi ce jeu je l'avais pas
j'avais un jeu bip bip mais c'était un
jeu sur megga drive donc du coup
celui-là j'ai dû le commander sur Ebay
pour ce test je me souviens de la
première fois cette frustration cette
difficulté j'essayé plein de technique
mais rien ne marché et encore là c'était
que pour ouvrir le colis après j'ai joué
au jeu et c'était pire heureusement que
je suis un grand fan des dessins animés
de Bip Bip ah [ __ ] s'il y a bien un
dessin animé Looney tons qui n'a
absolument pas vieilli franchement c'est
vraiment bip bip je veux dire l'humour
est est simple mais il y a rien à faire
ça marche à chaque
fois alors au niveau jeux vidéo il y a
eu d'excellents jeux sur bipip notamment
sur megga drive avec le super désert
démolition et il y a eu cette version
Super nest demandons son avis à
quelqu'un qui y a
joué alors graphiquement le jeu est très
bon il respecte bien l'esprit du dessin
animé niveau son bon ça va niveau
musique c'est potable mais bon c'est
bien beau tout ça mais si ça suffisait à
faire un bon jeu alors la megga CD
serait la meilleure console du monde
vous savez quand vous achetez un jeu bip
bip je suppose que la plupart des gens
s'attendent logiquement à un jeu qui va
vite hein je veux dire tout ce qui fait
rad Runner dans les dessins animé c'est
de courir à 200 km/h dans un désert et
on s'attend à un jeu qui ressemble à un
Sonic et ici il y a pas de problème vous
pouvez aller très très vite sauf que le
problème c'est que alleer vite égale
mourir dans ce jeu non mais je veux dire
waouh trop bien un jeu qui va plus vite
qu'un Sonic c'est super et j'ai plus
qu'à me faire greffer des yeux de ninja
pour pouvoir y jouer sérieusement c'est
cool de pouvoir aller aussi vite mais du
coup tu ne peux plus rien éviter tu te
manges absolument 100 % des pièges sur
le chemin parce que tu n'as pas le temps
de réagir enfit je veux dire
comprenez-moi bien regardez le détail de
cette scène j'ai utilisé le mon logiciel
de montage pour calculer à vitesse
normale sans le boost hein sans
l'accélérateur entre le moment où
l'objet apparaît sur le bord droit de
l'écran et le moment où je me le prends
dans la tronche il s'écoule
0,3 secondes c'est simplement plus
rapide que le temps de réaction d'un
humain normal et interroger ce médecin
et bien en fait il vous dira que j'ai
raison donc bref la conséquence de ça
ben à moins de connaître par cœur le jeu
et de savoir exactement où sont les
obstacles dans ce jeu tu ne dois pas
aller vite tu ne dois pas courir vous
allez tout juste trottiner tout
simplement si c'est pas limite marcher
pendant tout le niveau sérieusement un
jeu bip bip où il faut pas aller vite
sinon tu crèves mais c'est complètement
con c'est exactement comme si tu faisais
je sais pas un jeu Mario ou si tu sautes
tu
meurs Mia je me suis pété la jambe Mia
Mario tu es tombé VI prendre ce
champignon je ve pas de champignons
espèce de trop du cul Mons put la jambe
va me chercher un médecin ça sera
original ça tiens d'ailleurs à propos de
Mario ce jeu est beaucoup plus proche
d'un Mario que tu jouerais en vitesse
ultra accélérée que d'un Sonic un Sonic
à peu près n'importe quel idiot le finit
sans difficulté mais ce jeu ce n'est pas
un jeu de vitesse c'est purement un jeu
de plateforme où il faut être hyper
précis et comment veux-tu être hyper
précis avec un personnage qui va 10 fois
trop vite et qui fait des bons 10 fois
trop longs le moindre truc un peu
délicat ça devient une horreur
franchement je me suis jamais autant
retrouvé comme ça dans un jeu à galérer
sur des SAU pourtant qu'il sont simples
et tout pourris quoi là tout ce que je
dois faire ici c'est de monter en haut
mais il y a rien à faire j'arrive pas un
accélérant bouge-toi la nouille oh c'est
pas vrai quoi la gestion des saut je te
jure allez allez allez petit allez pour
la France allez tu vas l' voir allez ça
tu sers à rien
Pepito évidemment on n'oublie pas les
fondamentaux à savoir que si tu as une
droite de plus de 3 m c'est qu' a un
piège
toujours je me suis bien marré aussi sur
les salange ça c'était bien cool trop
loin
oui ah non put ah le mur allez oui non
oui non
oh voilà c'est comme ça qu'il faut quoi
tout ça pour un bonus de merde et en
plus je crève
oh d'ailleurs aussi en plus des trucs de
merde habituel genre les saut de l'ange
les checkpoint qui te ramènent plus lo
en arrière ce jeu a en fait développé le
concept du plateforme labyrinthe
regardez-moi ce niveau c'est l'anarchie
absolue parce que attention les jeux de
plateforme où tu vas bêtement de gauche
à droite c'est pour les [ __ ] dans
bip bip un niveau ça ressemble à ça
c'est
[Musique]
musique dynamique merde bon je passe
volontairement sur le scénario du jeu
qui te fait passer en l'espace de qu
niveaux du désert à une usine à une
grotte à un vaisseau extraterrestre j'ai
même pas envie de savoir ce qu'on fout
là concentrons-nous sur le niveau et
dans ce niveau donc tu dois passer deux
portails un portail pour avancer et
comme si c'était pas assez chien comme
ça et les portails te font bouger dans
tous les sens regardez-moi ce foutoir ça
monte ça descend ça va à gauche ça va à
droite tu prends le portail 4 qui
t'amène au portail 7 puis au 9 le 9
t'amène au 11 puis au 13 puis au 12 qui
te ramène au 9 sérieux c'est la maison
des fous comment est-ce que vous voulez
que je sache où est la fin de ce niveau
de merde quand j'arrête pas de bouger de
haut en bas et de gauche à droite j'ai
tellement bougé dans tous les sens que
je sais même pas si je suis proche du
début ou de la fin là en plus pour pas
t'aider il y a sans arrêt les martiens à
la con qui te foncent dessus sans
prévenir là sérieux comment vous voulez
que j'esquife ça ils font la taille de
l'écran merde sérieux ah mes fesses ah
non [ __ ] non non non non non non
[ __ ] votre vaissau spatial de merde on
dirait le tas d'échafaudage là vous avez
rien à branler qu'à faire du surf en
poursuivant une autreuche puttin le
sous-titre du jeu ça devrait être
beaucoup de souffrance pour un peu de
plaisir parce que ce jeu c'est pas
différent d'une séance de bondage en
plus moi je le fais avec le chi des 65
vies mais normalement faudrait tout
faire en moins de trois vies pas de
sauvegarde pas deue pas de mode passe
[ __ ] plutôt me rouler à poil dans des
ortill crève crève crève crève crève
crève crève crève crève
crève ça va c'est bon on a tous des
moments de faiblesse hein ça nous arrive
donc on va passer au jeu suivant
Tasmania sur megga Drive et si tu ranges
pas cette flute je te jure que je te
l'enfonce dans le Tasmania sorti en 92
sur megga drive la même année que bip
bip sur SuperNes alors déjà j'ai envie
de vous parler de tas un peu qui est pas
vraiment un des personnages les plus
connus de Warner hein à la base tas pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est surtout
un des méchants de l'univers de bug
Bunny le jeu vidéo Tasmania lui il est
adapté de la série Tasmania qui est
sorti entre 91 et
93 oh il n'a pas l'air dans son assiette
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça vous fait rire vous avez pas honte
sérieusement vous avez jamais remarqué
quelque chose qui vous a choqué dans
cette série la famille de Taz parle
parfaitement bien ses parents sa sœur
son frère il porte même des vêtements et
regarde des Taz
regardez-le c'est le seul à être à poil
en permanence et à ne pas savoir
parler oui Taz est mentalement handicapé
alors ne vous moquez plus de lui par il
est marrant ce con donc le scénario est
basique PAP tas vous raconte la légende
qu'il existe un œuf bien plus grand que
mon cul quelque part dans les montagnes
et donc vous partez le chercher et votre
famille n'en a absolument rien à branler
t va probablement crever bon de toute
façon je m'en fous en fait ça me
saoulait de le voir se promener à poil à
la maison le jeu quant à lui c'est un
jeu de plateforme bien classique et bien
pupute alors on va essayer quand même de
le hiérarchiser sur l'échelle
internationale de la
puputerie c'est bon vous avez toutu
alors pour commencer au niveau des
plateformes dans le niveau 1 vous avez
des espèces de G d'au et évidemment là
l'équipe de développement de ce jeu
s'est dit e et si on faisait l'inverse
des règles établies dans les jeux vidéos
développés depuis ces 20 dernières
années dans la plupart des jeux quand
vous êtes devant exactement la même
situation sauz dans ce jet d'eau vous
propulse vers le haut ici non ici vous
prenez des dégâts bon c'est pas
grandchose c'est un petit défaut mais ça
sera notre valeur et talon à un sur
l'échelle de la puputerie tomber en
dessous et mourir alors que visiblement
il y a de la terre et il y a une
plateforme en dessous niveau 2 sur
l'échelle bon on est en bas tuas
d'ailleurs une autre idée qui s le pâé
dans ce jeu c'est que chaque mouvement
chaque action chaque ennemi a son propre
effet sonore alors quand c'est bien fait
comme dans désertes démolition c'est
cool quand c'est mal fait c'est
complètement
saoulant quand ça saute on dirait qu' ça
fait un bruit de chat qui s'énerve j'en
sais rien quand il touche le sol ça fait
un bruit de klaxon en plus évidemment
c'est bien quand tu essayes de te
concentrer sur les plateformes tu sais
et pour les enemis c'est encore pire les
crabes font un bruit de sonnerie de
téléphone portable et surtout est-ce que
quelqu'un peut m'expliquer pourquoi cet
ennemi quand il marche a le même effet
sonore que de Hipi qui jouent du
[Musique]
jum voilà donc ça c'était les sons
séparés maintenant comme dans le jeu les
sons tous ensemble maintenant
donc passons au niveau 2 et maintenant
comme pour le plan fish pirate on va
passer l'échelle d'alerte de puputerie
au niveau rouge parce que évidemment Taz
ne peut pas s'empêcher de manger tout ce
qui lui passe sous la main même quand
c'est une bombe et que ça le tue et donc
là bien sûr les développeurs se sont
gavés en en mettant partout ok ok donc
là je quoi derrière le pilier c'est
c'est une blague [ __ ] oh ah je te jure
qu mais pile dessus on est pile dessus
mesdames et messieurs
[Applaudissements]
pantoufle c'est le premier mot qui me
vient à l'esprit pour pas être vulgaire
allez sors de làain il y a pas une loi
contre ça ben oui tiens B voilà là
mainant on t' met deux comme ça si tu
rates la première tu prends la seconde
put c'est de la cruauté gratuite ça mais
là les mecs ils ont dû se dire allez les
développeurs on va faire un jeu pour se
venger des connards qui achètent nos
produits qui est avec
moi là vous voyez sur l'échelle on est
déjà au niveau 6 mais on peut monter
plus haut dans le niveau 4 on a
levierers piégé tu dois tirer sur des
leviers pendant tout le niveau pour
couper le courant ça marche bien et
subitement à la fin sans prévenir tu as
certains leviers qui deviennent des
pièges et qui te tuent c'est gratuit
ensuite on a les niveaux sur de la glace
alors
ça il y a toujours un niveau sur de la
glace dans ce jeu qui te fait chier
c'est toujours ça fond dans la bouche il
y a aussi les niveaux avec les saut de
Lange bien sûr il y a les niveaux type
Froger où les mecs se sont dit he et si
on faisait un niveau en 3D avec des
sprit en 2D un grand moment de
jouissance dans ce niveaul parce qu'il y
en a plusieurs en plus bien sûr là vous
voyez il y a plein de couloirs qui sont
délimités par les trons il faut sauter
de Tron en Tron pour ne pas toucher la
flotte parce que votre Tron coule si
vous me pardonnez ce système c'est un
nétron merci mais votre personnage lui
que vous soyez devant au premier plan ou
derrière complètement en arrière-plan il
a exactement la même taille du coup
c'est génial parce que comme ça quand tu
sautes tu sais jamais où tu es je
rebondis je sais même pas où je suis
derrière devant et Bongi Bongi Bongi et
regarde-moi ça et tu meurs et tu meurs
et tu meurs et T pe choper le cancer
avec toutes ces tubeurs hein
ok j'ai mité dès que vous touchez l'eau
et que vous commencez à rebondir c'est
le festival il y a plus moyen de savoir
où c'est que vous allez atterrir et
attendez il y a mieux encore vous voyez
les rochers là sur l'eau peut-être que
vous croyez que c'est des zones sûres en
fait mais non on peut même pas rester
une seconde dessus pour reprendre son
souffle il y a sans arrêts des
crocodiles qui reviennent dessus pour
vous harceler en boucle [ __ ] mais une
seconde je te demande une seconde jeu de
merde laisse-moi juste fous-moi la paix
une seconde c'est trop demandé c'est
comme si dans un jeu tu mettais la pause
pour souffler pendant une seconde qu' y
a un mec qui vient de t'engueuler au
bout d'une seconde et demi lance lance
lance et enfin on a le niveau de la mine
le niveau de la mine le niveau de la
mine l'inévitable cliché du niveau de la
mine sérieux quoi ce jeu il a été fait
par captaine cliché quoi c'est pas
ok ok d'accord très bien franchement
j'ai même pas pu tester les boutons je
sais même ok donc le bouton ça sert à ça
donc bon je pourquoi j'ai fait ça c'est
pas vrai quoi ah parce qu'en plus il
faut gérer l'accélération aussi non mais
c'est c'est pas possible c'est juste pas
possible oh bah ah
sérieux au bas au bas oh B c'était allez
on recommence oh j'ai même pas démarré
làain de [ __ ] de
[ __ ] oh
oh
oh je suis passé j'étais passé là oh B
ohrê franchement même enant les
raccourcis sur une feuille ça suffirait
pas tellement ça va vite te faud une
copilote à côté
franchement
[Musique]
acclè cette fois je vais y arriver tu
vas voir de fois voilà c'est ça je suis
passé c'était comme
ça une quel part je vais comme une
merde
mer je pas
up
[Musique]